hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 1 video so so
much stuff happened we got a lot of
information not everything that we need
to find out who the villains are but I
think we have some clues about zoom in
the way they're going to be treating the
metahumans this season so I'll try to
explain earth to as well as some of the
new characters a new round of the
reverse flash ring giveaway starts now
Harrison wells sends you and his last
will and testament he's given all kinds
of rings away so you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video I'm actually gonna double
it it'll be two rings that I'm giving
away so let's do top 10 WTF moments
starting with Barry vs the Rogues with
firestorm great dream sequence that we
find out just like you know perfect
takedown everything is awesome and then
we get back to STAR Labs and it's like
wait a minute
everyone's so happy and Harrison wells
gets out of his chair he's not dead what
the hell's going on let me know the
minute you figured out that this was a
dream sequence for me it was when
Harrison wells wheeled up I was like
well clearly this isn't a flashback
because it's happening in present day
then he has that line where he says
there's nothing left that I have to
teach you it looks like you're ready to
do this on your own and then boom it
just flashes into present day very
awesome way to open the episode very
awesome transition to everything isn't
totally crazy and depressing but you
kind of see that like Barry has been
neglecting his normal life it almost
looks like there are bills piling up
bill later we find out that it's
something else on the number nine the
last will and testament of Harrison
wells so like it has to be said here
this is the reverse flash Harrison wells
isn't the original Harrison wells he has
that line where he's like I realized
that we're not enemies I helped raise
you all those years very very poignant
things I was surprised at how quickly he
turned around this is something he would
have recorded before that final fight
with Barry and he seemed pretty evil in
that final fight I was kind of expecting
him to give Barry something else but
when he said you know the thing that you
want most it was his father out of
prison but he does have that really
awesome line where he says it's not
going to make you happy like this won't
fix all your problems so he confesses to
the murder dad comes out everybody's
happy on the number 8 everybody is
getting a little bit happier Barry and
Caitlin's reunion this was actually one
of the most awkward and I and I think
one of the most touching ones to just
because you know how much she loved
Ronnie and they do think that he's dead
although he's definitely not dead I know
you're all wondering about fire
I'm sure just explain what happened
Ronnie either got sucked into earth too
or he got sucked into the firestorm
matrix there's a couple different ways
they could explain Ronnie coming back I
mean he'll definitely eventually come
back at a certain point but because this
J Jackson person is going to go to
legends of tomorrow I'm not expecting to
see Ronnie at least in present-day
anytime soon if we see him it'll be in
flashbacks it'll be like when Caitlin
remembers him I don't think that we're
gonna meet the new firestorm until
episode 3 I think this with all the
slates on all the trailers have been
saying but on a number 7 moving around
team flash iris still working at the
paper is kind of like Barry's voice of
reason she's kind of lone to like slaps
him in the face tells him to like get
out of his funk it mostly comes through
when they're fighting atom smasher like
but she has like a couple scenes with
him where she kind of says the same
thing where it's like okay time to move
on time to move forward that was like a
big theme of the episode moving forward
this is what needs to be done this is
why you need our help get a hold of
yourself stop being such a the
funny thing is is that this iris West
would have come in really handy during
arrow season 3 when Felicity was crying
too much you know she would just but
sugar like slept around a little bit get
a hold of yourself so if you're confused
about how iris is going to fit into team
flash and season 2 at least it seems
like this is how it's going to happen
she was the one that gave them the
information that they needed to figure
out what was going on with atom smashers
powers so if you look at team arrow just
imagine team flash splitting some of the
things that Felicity does iris collects
the information then Caitlin Cisco and
Martin Stein process it she's also
really important for Barry's emotional
journey so there's just like a number of
different places that they can fit her
in in episodes I won't say anything
about wally west yet just because we
haven't seen him but this is actually a
picture that the actor tweeted so it
looks like he's going to be a blonde on
the series which i think is pretty
interesting on the number 6 next stop on
team flash six months later cisco is now
working with Joe's metahuman task force
or at least it looks like he's slowly
starting to put it together I think as
we get more earth-2 villains it'll start
to coalesce the boot that he was making
for them in this episode was probably
just like the first of many things that
he's going to be making for them
Cisco will never stop making gadgets
that's one of the most fun things about
his character usually the best ones like
the guns end up getting him in the most
trouble I really love
way that they've continued the energy
that he and Joe have together they did
some side field trips together last
season and they're just kind of
continuing that this season like if you
remember the funny moment they had when
they went to Barry's old house last year
and the the Cougar was there expects a
lot more of that level of energy but but
now it just seems like they're that much
closer to being super Bros even though
technically Joe would be Cisco's boss on
the number 5 investigating the murder of
one Albert Rothstein
now Albert Rothstein is atom smasher
from the comics he's had a couple
different aliases the one that died is
the earth 1 version our version the one
that killed him was the earth 2 version
now they're just teeing this up episode
two like next week's episode is called
the flash of two worlds so that's when
they're really going to explain the
multiverse but you probably notice in
the background of this scene Jay Garrick
snapping pictures of the body I don't
think that he was photographing Barry's
so much as he was photographing the body
because he's from earth 2 so he's
investigating all the earth 2 villains
on the number 4 team flash versus atom
smasher most you recognize him but this
is edge from WWE very fun casting he
could come back I mean you're never
truly dead in the DC Universe but I'm
not expecting to see him again this
season now in the comics he doesn't need
radiation the way he needed it in this
episode to use his powers I think they
were just introducing that as a nice
twist and it's also kind of a reference
to nuke lon which was one of his other
aliases but on to number three Caitlin
snow and mercury labs so even though she
is working with team flash I wonder if
she's still going to continue her
relationship with mercury labs there
just seems that there's too much rich
untouched territory and in terms of
story that they could use there so they
built this set at mercury labs I have a
feeling that they'll probably keep it
and it provides some interesting
opportunities to surface
killer frost powers Caitlin snow was
confirmed as a metahuman last year we
just don't know when they're going to
decide to turn her into killer frost but
if she's performing some biology
experiment that's typically the way the
killer frost had been created in the
comics is through biology experiments
gone really really bad with sub-zero
temperatures so that might end up
happening at mercury labs speaking of
new metahumans number 2 Cisco uses his
powers again without really realizing it
I think I think he kind of understood as
it was happening but he decides not to
tell Joe about it
I am 96% sure that I am not responsible
for all those electrical vices going off
during the fight here's what I think is
going on with Cisco he is largely going
to look like Cisco this season but his
power gives him the ability to see other
timelines so instead of it being like a
flashback it's going to be a flash
sideways they can think of this year not
so much as in time travel but is in
crossing to other universes that you
know multiverse Theory the producers
have confirmed the gideon is no longer
at STAR Labs it doesn't exist anymore so
they're not going to be getting
knowledge about what happens in the
future instead of fighting their future
and fighting their past they're going to
be fighting sideways into another
reality so even though the theme of the
episode is moving forward think about
the theme of the season as moving
sideways and of course on my number one
WTF moment hello my name is Jay Garrick
so as you can see right off the bat Jay
Garrick Teddy Sears here
not nearly as old as the Jay Garrick
that you usually see in the comics he is
from earth-2 and he has been the flash
for a lot longer than Barry Allen has so
he's kind of going to be like a big
brother to Barry like a mentor here's
the twist though so if you remember in
season one that's kind of what Harrison
wells was turns out he was the wolf in
sheep's clothing like the wolf in the
henhouse the entire season that is why I
don't think that Jay Garrick is secretly
zoom I don't think they're going that
route again it'd be the exact same plot
line as last year I have seen some
flashpoint
Henry Allen theories in that Batman of
flashpoint is Thomas Wayne not Bruce
Wayne because Bruce is the one that died
the night that his parents were supposed
to die in the comics so like what if on
earth - Barry Allen dies as a child
Henry Allen gets flash powers and they
gets driven mad trying to save his son
turns into a big villain that's also
kind of a weak theory - because why
would he want to kill his son from Earth
- if he were his father and he were
trying to save him let me know who you
think zoom is right now I still think
the best theory is that it's an evil
future version of Wally West it's still
someone that is close to the family I
mean we don't really know what Wally
West's relationship is to Joe West but
he's still going to be part of the flash
family or the other option is is that it
could be the reverse flash from the
Golden Age the edward clariss reversed
either way we're gonna meet zoom for the
first time in Episode two that's called
the flash of two worlds now obviously
that's the first time in the comics the
Barry Allen met Jay Garrick so there
there's some minor changes because they
met in this episode but we will be
meeting patty spivot who's another
series regular she's going to be in most
of the episodes this season and also
just because we're seeing earth two
villains this season doesn't mean we
won't also see old villains come back
from earth one like Gorilla Grodd will
come back there's no way they would do a
season with the flash without Gorilla
Grodd and I've already mentioned most of
the comic book Easter eggs but I feel
like one of the best ones is Cisco's
comic book reference here I think I saw
it in a comic book somewhere my
inclination is is that this was just
intended to be used in this episode I
don't think that we're going to see the
flash signal and like every single
episode it's not going to be like a
Batman thing but Cisco totally on point
and he actually didn't get upset when
Martin Stein stole the naming convention
that usually goes to him I think they
gave Stein that moment just to make him
feel like part of a team as if naming a
metahuman was part of his initiation to
team flash so for the short term at
least until legends of tomorrow starts
it seems like Martin Stein is going to
be the new Harrison wells like the adult
advisor in the group I mean they're all
adults but he's like the real adult if
any of you have seen primer
I can't wait for like the flash primer
episode bring in Cisco just work through
the science of the multiverse and just
completely charted out in excruciating
detail you guys are definitely thinking
the same thing there's no way they're
ever going to do that as awesome as it
would be maybe DVD bonus features on all
just a great way to start the season I'm
super pumped I've you know I think we're
going to start to meet legends of
tomorrow characters as we get in through
the season there's a whole bunch of
stuff though so don't expect to see
everybody right at the same time just to
give you guys an idea about Vandal
Savage legends of tomorrow
that's episode 8 we're going to meet
Vandal Savage in episode 8 it's the big
flash versus arrow crossover last year
they made the comment that like you
could watch the arrow episode in the
flash episode out of order and they
would still kind of make sense this year
they said it's kind of like one giant
story stretched out over three different
shows so it's really important that you
watch arrow whenever it airs and then
legends of tomorrow next year when it
premieres the legends of tomorrow isn't
going to start airing until like January
maybe even like February next year I
think it'll start in January and just
for reference I am going to be doing q
and A's for
is an arrow on Thursday so just leave
all your questions and then after arrow
tomorrow I'll post a Q&A on Thursday so
much awesome stuff coming next week
can't wait to meet patty spivot she's
going to be an awesome character zoom
can't wait to see what his costume ends
up looking like so why guys wait for
that you can click here for all my arrow
and flash trailer videos and you can
click here for my Gotham episode that I
just posted last night thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow